in the 21st century speak the words city
and you conjure images of skyscrapers
great urban skylines are forests of tall
steel framed buildings super tall
structures like the Burj Khalifa in
Dubai or the Petronas Towers in Kuala
Lumpur are used to announce the
emergence of a city on the global stage
but for millennia we had cities without
tall towers Europe is still dotted with
major metropolis such as Rome that are
almost completely without skyscrapers
the skyscrapers invention in the late
19th century is itself an example of how
cities can solve their own problems
by allowing collaborative chains of
creativity for thousands of years the
Great Pyramid of Giza was the world's
tallest structure standing as a monument
to the coercive powers of the Pharaohs
as well as to Egyptian engineering but
finally in the 14th century church
spires began to push above its 481 foot
height Lincoln Cathedral in England may
have reached 525 feet in 1311 but it's
tall wooden spire was demolished by a
violent storm during the turbulent reign
of Edward the 6th after its destruction
the global height record was held by a
series of church towers st. Mary's in
strass London Strasbourg st. Nick Lyon
Hamburg Notre Dame in rural and finally
Cologne which was only completed in 1880
and soon lost its preeminence to the
Washington Monument and then the
towering Eiffel Tower which soared 300
metres above Paris vastly higher than
any earlier building the Eiffel Towers
wrought iron structure points to a
central engineering element of the
skyscraper a steel or cast iron skeleton
that bears the weight of the building
indeed a reasonable view is that the
skyscraper can be defined as a tallish
building perhaps with at least 10
storeys with elevators and a metal frame
this definition emphasizes that the
skyscraper depended on combining two
19th century technologies high-quality
metal production and safe elevators
metal had been used in building for over
a millennium the Chinese who are master
metal workers produced cast-iron pagodas
in the seventh century but before the
Industrial Revolution metal was
expensive and uneven
quality in fact one reason why James
Watt moved from Glasgow to make his
separate condenser steam engines was
that he needed high quality metal
cylinders which could be supplied in
Birmingham from the nearby furnaces of
the legendary John iron mad wilkinson
great innovations regularly require
collaboration which is why cities like
Watts Birmingham have so often been hubs
of invention the Industrial Revolution
powered by Watts steam engines turned
high-quality iron into a plausible
building material
Wilkinson himself played a major role in
building the world's first cast-iron
bridge William strut built textile mills
with wooden beams that were encased by
sheet iron to reduce the risk of fires
Charles beige did him one better by
building the dithering Tain's mill with
an entirely iron frame this may be the
world's first iron frame building and a
proto skyscraper an iron frame means
that the weight of the building is borne
not by the walls but by a metal skeleton
the facade is hung like a sheet on this
underlying frame so while traditional
mass wall construction requires
unbelievably thick walls or perhaps
flying buttresses to support great
height framed buildings can have thin
light walls even walls of glass
since the skeleton is actually holding
up the structure consequently metal
frame buildings became particularly
popular for uses that benefit from light
80 Stuart was one of New York's greatest
merchants and his salesmanship made him
one of the richest men in history he
realized that displaying merchandise on
the ground floors of his stores would
lure in New York City's heavy pedestrian
traffic and so he built his 1848 marble
palace with big windows facing the
street the windows made the ground floor
walls weak and to hold up the rest of
the structure his architect used
cast-iron columns for the support in
1862 Stuart brought in even more light
with his iron palace built with a
complete cast iron skeleton windows are
even more useful in greenhouses which is
why Joseph Paxton a towering figure in
Victorian horticulture became an artist
when he built with cast-iron
Paxton won the competition to build a
home for London's Great Exhibition of
1851 his Crystal Palace was another
precursor to the skyscraper and
and compassed almost 1 million square
feet with 4,000 tons of iron and 900,000
square feet of glass
Paxton would influence other architects
like Victor Baltar who used cast iron to
build Paris's Central Market LaSalle and
the iron beam supported church of st.
Augustine New York built its own Crystal
Palace in 1853 and the next year Elisha
Otis dazzled the crowds within its walls
he stood high on an elevator and ordered
the rope holding it to be cut his fall
was almost immediately broken by the
safety catch that Otis had designed
Otis's elevators made it safe to move
vertically and in 1870 New York's iron
framed equitable Life Assurance Building
rose to 130 feet and became the first
office building to offer elevators high
floors had been tough to rent because
tenants disliked walking up all those
stairs
Otis changed all that and unleashed the
commercial possibilities of building
architectural historians have often
referred to Chicago's home insurance
building built in 1884 as the world's
first skyscraper and its architect
William LeBaron Jenny has often been
called the father of the skyscraper but
naturally there's a lively architectural
history debate about this home insurance
only has steel framing on the outer
walls
moreover home insurance is only eight
feet taller than New York's earlier
equitable building although it does have
10 rather than seven storeys but the
montauk building erected a few years
earlier than home insurance by Daniel
Burnham and John route also had 10
storeys Burnham and root would build
Chicago's towering 21 story Masonic
Temple a few years later Burnham would
also bring the innovations the Chicago
School into New York with his Flatiron
Building
maybe Burnham or root are the real
fathers of the skyscraper or maybe Louis
Sullivan whose architectural vision
imagined skyscrapers that fully embraced
the potential of the steel frame or
maybe Peter be white the great
fireproofing engineer really deserves
the credit I think that the search for
any single father of the skyscrapers
actually a fool's errand for the
skyscraper like pretty much every other
great human invention is a collaborative
creation all of these Chicago architects
knew each other Sullivan and Burnham
both worked as apprentices for Jenni
Oh liberally borrowed ideas from one
another Jenny made a first step that
relied heavily on even earlier
innovations from Birmingham to New York
and the others rift on his start if
anything the city of Chicago deserves
the credit for it assembled a remarkable
collection of architectural talent to
rebuild after its great fire that talent
connected by urban density
collaboratively figured out how to make
buildings that soared and it's soared
beautifully the skyscraper is a reminder
of how cities solve their own problems
in this case the need to fit more usable
space on a finite amount of land by
enabling smart people to learn from one
another
you